until bed do his part more American
couples are getting check this out a
sleep divorce and choosing to hit the
sack in different rooms from their
spouse more than a third are going to
bed separately to avoid snoring stolen
covers and their partner's early alarms
some say it works wonders for their
marriage
um Jesse is this you you find that this
was a strategy that you're pursuing I
don't snore so that's not a problem
she steals covers I steal them back so
we're even
the alarm thing is an issue she's making
me put my alarm in in like the bathroom
and then she doesn't like the bathroom
area door opens so she makes me and then
I can't hear it because the door was
closed so then I bought one of those
classic ones that like you don't plug in
and you just put it and that's too loud
so that's a real issue in the marriage
right now well if you let her have the
covers maybe you wouldn't have to deal
with that there's plenty of covers to go
around judge there is
[Laughter]
when I was in the White House years
um I I wasn't a great sleeper and Peter
snored quite a bit and I was not kind
okay it's like some wives would be like
oh please honey could you turn over I
was like I would get so mad because as
soon as I woke up that was me up for the
rest of the night somehow he stopped
snoring I don't know how so that has
been very good I understand why my
grandparents eventually did because the
snoring thing can drive you crazy
um I think that
trying to stay together in the bedroom
is very important I also though
understand it's not just the alarm it's
the light at night of the phone yeah oh
yeah and like can you turn that off are
you like and also if you're scrolling
through Instagram and all of a sudden it
starts playing like horrible music
that has happened once no phone's in bed
um you got a perspective on this yes I
uh I'm your rack of ribs for this yes
the worst thing I've I mean I got a
French Bulldog that thing that snores
like a a rest home of Carnival clowns I
mean it's just like so the north I mean
the noises that come out of a French
Bulldog are straight out of like a
Warner Brothers cartoon from the like
the 1930s it's like
people know this if you have one like
you'll wake up and you'll hear this
insane noise and you don't even know
what orifice it's coming from but you
know what I was thinking would it isn't
the the opposite of that better like not
a sleep divorce but a waking divorce so
you just never see your spouse until you
go to bed
is that good like never see them at all
and then you come in like you're like uh
like you you know you're like stranger I
mean it's a take you know what I'm
saying because you know what kills you
know being around people that's what
kills the marriage let's be honest
marriages die because you get sick of
people make her miss you yes exactly you
guys are wrong it's a strategy
uh what do you think about this uh
foreign
what's going on here I got nothing to
say I have three Standard Poodles they
don't snore I'm very good no they're in
bed with you no they're in the bedroom
they're not in bed with me they're
bigger than I am okay but they don't
snore they're very nice you know what
look I I think a good night's sleep is
essential all right if you can work it
out so that the two of you can sleep
together like I leave my phone my phone
is my alarm but I keep it down so I
don't see the light at night
um and I like the the lights the shades
open and most yeah
and I like we're not sleeping together
no we're not ever no um and then
and then and then I like I like a lot of
covers okay and that's the end of my
life I think that people should sleep in
the same bed but have separate bathrooms
without saying yeah that's the only
reason my marriage lasted as long as it
did
32 years
congratulations hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else